what would a space battle really be like
welcome to star trek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
so i am a sucker for an amazing space
battle one of my subscribers actually
calls it um spaceship pawn um but i and
i kind of agree with him it's gratuitous
space battles i actually love that in
star trek it's the favorite bits of my
movies you know the wrath of cards space
battle amazing
so
are shields are trapping
raise them
i can't
where's the override the override
fire
um undiscovered country space battle
amazing star trek nemesis space battle
not a very good film but a good space
battle
so for me
i love that
but what would a space battle in reality
actually look like would it be anything
like as exciting as what we see on the
screens
well i'm gonna have a think about what
sort of weapon systems i imagine will be
available to these big space armadas in
the future and what a space battle would
actually look like
first of all let's consider the missile
systems
we would probably still have some sort
of projectile self-propelled projectile
that we would consider nowadays to be a
missile or a photon torpedo if you like
that would be fired at our enemies
now the thing is at the moment in star
trek in particular those ships are a
couple hundred meters apart firing and
there's quite a small explosion well we
know from our own common sense that at
the very least a warhead even if it was
a couple of meters long would have a
nuclear warhead if nothing else it would
have to have a warhead
at least more powerful than that if you
had antimatter warhead for example it
would actually be incredibly powerful
the boom would be and the shock wave
that it would create would be
massive
without some sort of shields but we'll
talk about fences later without some
sort of shields one missile would be
enough not just to destroy an enemy
vessel but to completely vaporize it
but how could missiles or torpedoes work
if i was firing on an enemy target i
would fire my torpedo at it at great
distance maybe even hundreds of
thousands of miles
and allow the torpedo to just go in that
direction i would only then activate the
torpedo when it got reasonably close
then lock onto the target and then maybe
thrust one more time just into the to
hit the target other weapons though
include potentially rail guns this is
something that is currently in
development today a railgun is a very
simple technology really you have
electromagnetic coils
and the projectile is pushed along those
and can be fired in incredible speeds
you can also because there's no sort of
mechanical element to them you can fire
lots of projectiles really really fast
we see railguns in lots and lots of tv
series because they are actually a
realistic technology these are weapons
that being developed and particularly by
the us navy at the moment but they would
also be very very good weapons at say
shooting down enemy photon torpedoes or
enemy missiles or enemy fighters they
are one reason why in a realistic space
battle i don't think we would actually
see fighters they could be shredded like
how today fighters don't go anywhere
near enemy combat vessels anything
capital vessels large because they have
very large um radar-guided midi guns on
them those miniguns are very capable of
shredding anything that comes near them
i think
i think railguns would be a very good
defensive tactic but also actually they
would be quite a good offensive weapon
because again you could fire a lot of
projectiles at an enemy say medium range
say 100 000 miles even and those
projectiles would fly straight and true
towards that enemy now the enemy might
move in the meantime so you might miss a
lot but they're a very cheap weapon
you're literally the slugs are literally
just lumps of aluminium or something
else you just fire bomb scatter shot you
just fire a lot and some will hit and
when they hit they will hit with
incredible force
but that moves us on to more sci-fi
weapons
particle beam weapons are actually again
something that's being developed at the
moment we mostly base those weapons on
microwaves but or laser technology we
don't know what that would be in the
future but particle being technology
doesn't really work very well in an
atmosphere because you've got atmosphere
to hit particles in the atmosphere get
hit by the beam and they deflect parts
of the weapon it's called blooming in an
atmosphere energy weapons are
very difficult to to work and not
particularly powerful and you need to be
reasonably close
but in space there is very little for an
energy weapon to hit there is particles
in space of course and space dust and
things like this but
barely any and it's very very sparse so
energy weapons are far more powerful an
energy blast from a high-energy weapon
like this would travel at the speed of
light at three million meters per second
that is you know you see on star trek
again the phase is
coming across the beam you can see it
going across it wouldn't be like that it
would be like
[Music]
[Music]
very very fast and incredibly long
ranges again these ships a couple of
hundred meters apart
wouldn't look like that you know you
could you could shoot at an enemy three
million meters away and hit it in a
second finally i'm gonna vote to quickly
talk about plasma weapons because this
is again something that is being
developed at the moment the russian
federation in particular is very
interested in plasma weapon technology
plasma is basically just very very
excited mass it's basically if you take
it take a lump of anything and make it
exciting to pump enough energy into it
you create eventually plasma
now that is very simple and scientists
are going to get angry at me for that
example but a very simple level that's
how it works
so you get a plasma weapon you get some
matter you excite enough and you fire it
at an enemy in space i don't know if
that would be particularly long range i
don't know if it dispersed i don't know
if the plasma would basically cool in
space at long ranges um
but it is a weapon system that is being
currently developed on earth so i'd say
no reason why it couldn't be available
for space battles in the future but what
would space battles actually then look
like well i've already sort of hinted at
it a little bit haven't i though any
space battles would probably be fought
at massive distances
the way i was thinking about it was a
naval battles of old so naval battles
back in the day world war one world war
ii
they would be fought over days they
would be fought over hundreds of miles
potentially because one of the first
problems you'd have is actually finding
your enemy your best defense if you're
fighting in space that's very very big
is to make it very difficult for your
enemy to find you
your first problem in any sort of space
battle is going to be finding your enemy
and then again not losing them because
another factor about fighting in space
is that your ships can be very very fast
and potentially maneuver very very
quickly
so find your enemy don't lose your enemy
and then actually be able to attack them
you have weapon systems that would be
able to operate on massive distances so
waiting for your enemy to sort of like
go toe to toe with each other just
wouldn't happen you'd be able to kill
each other at hundreds of thousands of
miles potentially i consider the weapon
system that'd be most interesting for me
with like an active mine you know the
missile system i was talking about where
you fire and sort of forget about it you
could drop hundreds of them and just
wait for an enemy to come into range or
fire them roughly in the direction you
know they are and wait for the one of
them to detect something
you would have sensor technology
obviously that you could use to detect
and find your enemy but you've got
basically two kinds of sensors active
and passive
this is something that submarines have
to contend with all the time that if you
use their active sensors and that is
mean you project some sort of energy out
like radar or something like that to
detect something so you send out some
energy that energy bounces off the um
target and you can detect that but if
you do that you become detectable
because you are emitting energy
passive senses basically work by just
detecting that
so somebody sends out some energy and
you detect it
heat could be a passive sensor
potentially because you could use
cameras to look for it
so again if a spaceship though was
designed to not emit not emit energy and
not emit light it would actually be very
difficult to detect without some sort of
active sensor array that would again
lead into the fact that space battles
would probably last over weeks
there would be cat and mouse sort of
coming in maybe firing off a few rounds
and then disappearing again
it would be
hunting your enemy down
desperately constantly trying to find
them if you then add in things like
shields and defenses again like saying
like using the rail guns to shoot down
any missiles that come in within range
or using energy shields to defend
yourself against energy weapons if those
shields were any sort of effective then
you would have to hit your enemy
potentially a lot before making any
serious damage but again prolonging any
battle so having capital ships that were
survivable would be very very important
because if a missile did go off it would
potentially destroy you in one hit we
actually saw this in battlestar
galactica that they used the rail guns
as a as a shield
as a as a hard shield basically and that
when a nuclear weapon then did hit them
the battle star was built strong enough
to survive that but it caused massive
damage and they actually nearly lost
part of the ship from it
so
that would be the case that if you were
hit by any sort of hard weapon and that
by by that i mean some sort of missile
or something that is going to cause
devastating destruction
unless you have some way of countering
it so what would space battles look like
in reality the chances are they'd be
quite boring they'd take quite a long
time and they'd be fought without you
ever actually seeing the enemy
so
it wouldn't really work for a good
sci-fi movie
i say that
i watch things like i'm i watch a lot of
old war movies and the tactics and the
chess-like way of a battle like this
would progress
would be really really interesting and
from a character point of view having
the captain trying to out fox the enemy
oh that'd be a great movie wouldn't it
so maybe we should actually write a
script that is more realistic
because it would actually create a very
tense
drama-filled thriller of a sci-fi movie
that's a movie i'd love to see
but get in the comments guys tell me
what you think what do you think a space
battle would really look like in real
life um what sort of weapon systems do
you think we'll have in the future and
what sort of defenses do you think could
be realistically possible in the future
i'd love to know because i'm sure you
guys will think of lots of things i
haven't
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit the bell notification
it really helps us out and if you
enjoyed the content and the little
conversation that we've had consider
hitting the join button and becoming a
fully fledged side tracker as always
please stay safe i'll see you next time
[Music]
you